THE UKRAINIAN ARMY MADE ANOTHER
SUBSTANTIAL GAIN OVER THE
WEEKEND.
IT RETOOK THE EASTERN CITY OF
LYMAN HOURS AFTER RUSSIA
ILLEGALLY CLAIMED IT AS PART OF
ITS SHAM REFERENDUM.
NICK PATON WALSH AND HIS TEAM
WERE ON THE GROUND MOMENTS AFTER
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT CON
CONFIRMED RUSSIA HAD MOVED OUT.
GIVE US THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: WE'RE THE FIRST
TELEVISION CREW INTO LYMAN TO
SEE THE DEVASTATION CAUSED BY
THIS AND SEE HOW GHOSTLY EMPTY
IT WAS AND HEAR FROM LOCALS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT SOME RUSSIAN
TROOPS MANAGED AN ORDERLY
WITHDRAWAL AT ROUGHLY THE SAME
TIME THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS
STANDING ON A STAGE RALLYING
PEOPLE TOWARDS VICTORY, SIGNING
PIECES OF PAPER FORCING LYMAN TO
BE PART OF RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
PERHAPS WHY THIS IS SUCH A
STRATEGIC DEFEAT FOR RUSSIA.
HERE'S WHAT WE SAW.
IT MAY NOT LOOK LIKE MUCH BUT
THIS IS WHERE PUTIN'S DEFEAT IN
DONETSK BEGAN.
A PRIZE FROM THE LAST CENTURY
PERHAPS BUT TRAINS AND TRACKS
ARE STILL HOW RUSSIA WAGES WAR
TODAY.
LYMAN, WHAT'S LEFT OF IT, NOW
FREED OF RUSSIAN RUSSIA.
THIS IS WHAT IT WAS ABOUT, THE
RAILWAY HUB NOW IN UKRAINIAN
HANDS AND DEVASTATED BY THE
FIGHTING.
AND THIS WAS SUCH A SEMINAL PART
OF RUSSIA'S OCCUPATION OF
DONETSK AND LUHANSK THE CONCERN
FOR MOSCOW IS THE EFFECT THIS
HAS ON THE FORCES ALL THE WAY TO
THE RUSSIAN BORDER.
ON THE TOWN'S EDGES WE SAW NO
SIGN OF HUNDREDS OF RUSSIAN
PRISONERS OR DEAD THAT HAD BEEN
EXPECTED TO FOLLOW MOSCOW'S
STRATEGIC DEFEAT HERE.
NOR INSIDE IT.
PERHAPS THEY HAVE ALREADY BEEN
TAKEN AWAY.
ONLY SILENCE INSTEAD.
BICYCLES ON THE STREET.
SEVERAL RESIDENTS TOLD US THE
RUSSIANS LEFT IN LARGE NUMBERS
ON FRIDAY.
>> Translator: THEY LEFT IN THE
NIGHT AND DAY PEOPLE SAID.
I DIDN'T SEE IT MYSELF BUT THEY
SAT ON THEIR APCs AND BAGS WERE
FALLING OFF AS THEY DROVE.
THEY RAN LIKE THIS.
>> Reporter: IT WOULD BE
REMARKABLE TIMING THAT RUSSIA
FLED IN THE SAME HOURS THAT
PUTIN WAS SIGNING PAPERS
DECLARING LYMAN RUSSIAN
TERRITORY AND HOLDING A RALLY ON
RED SQUARE.
AND THE LOCAL ADMINISTRATION,
THE ONLY SIGNS OF RUSSIA LEFT
ARE BURNED FLAGS.
THEY RAN AWAY WITHOUT SAYING A
WORD TO ANYBODY HE SAYS.
IT WAS BAD, NO WORK, NO GAS, NO
POWER, NOTHING.
THE SHOPS DIDN'T WORK.
IT TRULY FEELS AS IF THERE IS
NOBODY LEFT.
GHOSTLY SILENCE HERE, APART FROM
OCCASIONAL SHELLING AND SMALL
ARMS FIRE.
AND IT IS FOR SO MUCH OF THIS
TOWN UTTERLY DESTROYED.
SO MANY LOCALS WE'RE TOLD
LEAVING WHEN THE UKRAINIAN PUSH
TOWARD IT BEGAN.
BUT NOW IT'S JUST THIS UTTER
GHOSTLINESS IN A PLACE THAT'S
SUCH A STRATEGIC DEFEAT FOR
RUSSIA.
GUN FIRE IN THE DISTANCE.
THEY'RE NERVOUS SOME RUSSIANS
MAY BE LEFT.
OUTSIDE WHAT'S LEFT OF THE
COURT, THE CONSTANT CHANGE IN
VIOLENCE IS TOO MUCH FOR SOME.
HER HUSBAND, JUST ARRESTED.
>> Reporter: THE UKRAINIAN
TROOPS WE DID SEE HAD ALREADY
STOPPED SEGRCELEBRATING.
THERE IS LITTLE TIME.
THEY'RE ON THE MOVE AGAIN.
ANOTHER RUSSIAN TARGET FURTHER
EAST, IN THEIR SIGHTS.
AND THOSE LEFT IN LYMAN, A TOWN
CURSED TO HAVE THESE BARS OF
RUSTING STEEL RUNNING THROUGH
IT, ARE GATHERING THE RUINS TO
BURN FOR FUEL WITH WINTER AHEAD.
LEFT IN THE WAKE OF RUSSIA'S
COLLAPSE HERE, A TOWN THEY TOOK
WEEKS TO OCCUPY BUT ONLY HOURS
TO LEAVE.
NOW, THE STAGGERING MILITARY
DEFEAT IS SEEING AN EFFECT
ALREADY ON RUSSIA'S BORDERS, BUT
THERE'S POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES
BICKERING AMONGST RUSSIA'S E
ELITE, CRITICISM FROM THE
RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA AND THE
KREMLIN SAYING THEY ARE STILL
DISCUSSING WITH THE LOCAL
POPULATIONS THE AREAS OF
ZAPORIZHZHIA AND KHERSON THAT
THEY OCCUPY, HOW MUCH OF THOSE
AREAS IN THEIR MIND ARE RUSSIAN
TERRITORY.
DISARRAY FRANKLY FROM THE
MILITARY STANDPOINT.
STARTLING DAYS AHEAD AND JUST
BEHIND US HERE.
>> NICK PATON WALSH, THANK YOU
FOR THAT REPORT.
>> TERRIFIC REPORTING.